tarifa gefahr ist auf dem weg zur arbeit
von kabul in die provinz wardak bevor
sie die stadt verlässt muss sie sich
beim polizeikommandanten der strecke
melden
ich weiß nicht was mit der kommunikation
nicht stimmt sie nicht hören aber ich
habe gerade kabul verlassen ich brauche
ihre hilfe wären meiner fahrt wir sind
noch nicht in sack in welchem gebiet
sind die sicherheitskräfte nur mit
bewaffnetem begleitschutz kann sich zur
ifa davari bewegen
schon kurz hinter kabul führt die route
mitten durch taliban gebiet überall ist
militär zu sehen
die armee hat checkpoints errichtet die
wir nur aus dem auto filmen können denn
auch die soldaten fürchten um ihr leben
afghanistan ist im krieg die regierung
kontrolliert heute nur noch die großen
städte tarif us ziel ist die
provinzhauptstadt medan schau deren
bürgermeisterin die 29-jährige ist zwei
stunden ist sie unterwegs denn in der
stadt wie sie regiert kann sie nicht
wohnen
einer der gründe warum ich nicht in
meydan charlotta klebl ist dass dieser
ort nicht sicher genug für mich ist es
ist zu gefährlich
sharifs vater wurde von den taliban
ermordet und auch sie hat einen anschlag
auf ihr auto nur knapp überlebt das
fahrzeug wurde aus dem hinterhalt
beschossen
meistens kommen sie aus den bergen sie
nutzen dann die bäume und häuser oder
diese zementfabriken an der straße um
sich zu verstecken
ankunft in meydan so selbstverständlich
wie an diesem morgen startet nicht jeder
arbeitstag tarifa gefahr wurde nicht
gewählt sondern 2018 von der regierung
in kabul eingesetzt
den respekt der männer mit denen sie
zusammenarbeitet hat sie sich hart
erkämpft hat sie sich immer wieder auch
social media zunutze gemacht als
bewaffnete sie daran hindern wollten im
büro zu betreten richtete sie eine
videobotschaft an die öffentlichkeit
leute ich bin hier vor dem
bürgermeisteramt
hier ist gerade ein mächtiger warlord
mit drei bewaffneten vor dem eingangstor
aufgetaucht er ist hier mit drei oder
vier jungen männern
sie stehen wir sie wollen mich nicht in
das büro des gouverneurs und in das
bürgermeisterbüro rein gehen lassen
[Musik]
seit drei jahren bis tarifa nun schon
bürgermeisterin inzwischen kommandiert
sie ein ganzes team von männern in der
stadtverwaltung
sie will die korruption bekämpfen die
wirtschaft aufbauen
faulheit und ausreden duldet sie nicht
wenn nötig kann sie auch laut werden
tarifa weiß sie braucht schnelle erfolge
und muss das vertrauen der bevölkerung
in einer extrem konservativen und
rückständigen staat gewinn in der frauen
so gut wie gar nicht in der
öffentlichkeit zu sehen sind
seitdem sich das corona virus in
afghanistan rasant verbreitet ist der
job noch gefährlicher denn nur wenige
männer die sie an diesem tag sieht
tragen masken die bürgermeisterin trifft
einen stammesführer dessen bruder vor
kurzem von den taliban ermordet wurde
sie spricht ihr beileid aus und wünschte
seine feinde mögen erblinden und sein
schmerz bald vergehen
meine soldaten sind stark ich habe heute
weitere 130 männer gefunden
selbst wenn sie die gesamte gegend mit
landminen überziehen machen wir weiter
[Musik]
und dann zum abschied erklärt der
stammesführer der bürgermeisterin
ich stehe dir immer zu diensten ich habe
keine angst von niemandem die lage in
meydan csa ist typisch für die des
gesamten landes nur mit massivem einsatz
von sicherheitskräften
schafft es die regierung die stadt zu
schützen sollten die usa in den
kommenden monaten wie geplant ihre
truppen abziehen stellt sich auch für
die bürgermeisterin die frage ob sie
sich weiter im amt
tarifa wird inzwischen auch
international als hoffnungsträgerin für
afghanistan angesehen
von der us-regierung wurde sich für
ihren mut ausgezeichnet
dass die amerikaner eine vereinbarung
mit den taliban getroffen haben
hält sie für falsch und auch die
friedensgespräche die die afghanische
regierung mit vertretern der
aufständischen führt kritisiert sie
scharf
zunächst einmal warum sollten wir wieder
die kosten für einen frieden mit den
taliban zahlen seit 20 jahren bezahlen
wir schon die kosten seit 20 jahren
werden jedes jahr tausende von soldaten
getötet und hunderte von zivilisten
ermordet ich denke es reicht jetzt wir
haben genug bezahlt für den frieden
wenn die afghanische regierung bereit
ist noch weitere kosten zu zahlen um
frieden zu erreichen
dann denke ich ist das eine große chance
für die regierung
ich bin nicht bereit noch weitere opfer
für den frieden zu bringen weitere
zugeständnisse zu machen und an dass
krieg bedeutet dann werde ich an der
front sein und für unsere rechte zu
kämpfen
nach 20 jahren nato-einsatz und
internationalen hilfszahlungen in
milliarden-höhe stellt sich heute die
frage klären die taliban die 2002 von
den usa und ihren verbündeten vertrieben
wurden an die macht zurück vor allem für
die frauen steht viel auf dem spiel denn
das immerhin ist eine erfolgsgeschichte
der wandel hat den frauen in afghanistan
freiheit und chancen verschafft
wenn es um die errungenschaften der
vergangenen 20 jahre geht wird der blick
immer wieder auf afghanistans schulen
das mädchen und jungen gleichermaßen
zugang zu bildung bekommen war eines der
großen ziele westlichen engagements in
afghanistan
die maria ward schule im westen kabuls
ist eine berühmte eliteschule und hat
uns die möglichkeit gegeben auf dem
pausenhof und im klassenzimmer zu drehen
geschichtsunterricht die mädchen stammen
alle aus liberalen familien die wollen
dass ihre töchter gut ausgebildet sind
einige von ihnen wollen nach der schule
studieren
fatima jusufi die lehrerin musste
heimlich lesen und schreiben lernen in
einer untergrund schule unter großer
gefahr
die 33 jährige wuchs unter dem
taliban-regime auf in einer zeit in der
mädchen aus schulen und universitäten
ausgeschlossen wurden und frauen
praktisch rechtlos waren diese neue
generation sollte ein leben in frieden
führen können
jeder sollte die gleichen rechte haben
männer frauen sollten gleichberechtigt
sein
diese neue generation sollte ein leben
in frieden führen können
jeder sollte die gleichen rechte haben
männer und frauen sollten
gleichberechtigt seien eine schule zu
besuchen ist der afghanische kinder
insbesondere mädchen bis heute ein
privileg nur die hälfte aller kinder
erhält einen platz noch immer gibt es
nicht genug gebäude noch immer fehlen
ausreichend ausgebildete lehrer
[Musik]
nur 40 prozent aller mädchen können
heute in afghanistan einen abschluss
machen die schülerinnen der maria ward
schule wollen sich ihr leben nicht mehr
aus der hand nehmen lassen
die afghanischen frauen werden nicht
zurückweichen
wir haben viel gelitten um das hier zu
erreichen um hier zu sein und wir werden
nicht aufgeben für das zu kämpfen was
wir erreicht haben
auch wenn es hart wird ich habe hoffnung
dass wir in der zukunft in einer
friedlichen umgebung leben werden ob die
taliban es wollen oder nicht wir werden
studieren
ob sie wollen oder nicht wir werden
sport treiben
wenn sie uns nach diesen 18 jahren noch
einmal einsperren wollen dann können sie
das vergessen die afghanischen frauen
haben sich stark verändert
sie können uns nicht mehr zwingen zu
hause zu bleiben
bei den dreharbeiten in der kabuler
marie fahrschule erleben wir erstaunlich
selbstbewusster und redegewandte mädchen
eine neue generation von afghanen
auch edda starb gehört zu dieser neuen
generation sie fährt selbst auto in
kabul
einer der gefährlichsten städte der welt
richterinnen journalistinnen werden auf
offener straße ermordet
da weiß auch sie kann zum ziel werden
ich habe angst
die sicherheitslage in afghanistan hat
sich so sehr verschlechtert durch kabul
zu fahren ist viel gefährlicher geworden
besonders für frauen wenn wir unser auto
abstellen müssen wir fürchten dass sie
magnet bomben anbringen
überall gibt es anschläge und wir haben
auch angst davor gekidnappt zu werden
im fotostudio bereitet sich dafür
aufnahmen vor sie ist afghanistans
bekanntestes model unverschleiert tritt
sie vor der kamera auf und verkörpert
damit das lebensgefühl der modernen und
jungen afghanen
inzwischen hat sich die 26 jährige auch
als influenza in einen namen gemacht
[Musik]
223.000 menschen folgen hier auf
instagram fotos die ein anderes
frauenbild vermitteln
eines das für die taliban nicht
akzeptabel ist vor allem in letzter zeit
hat sie immer wieder morddrohungen
erhalten wie viele sieht auch sie
afghanistan am wendepunkt
ich fürchte wenn die taliban in die
regierung kommen werden wir alles was
wir in den vergangenen jahren in diesem
land erreicht haben wieder verlieren
ich habe im ausland studiert ich bin
zurückgekommen um ein geschäft
aufzumachen vermitteln was wenn wir
unsere freiheit wieder verlieren und wir
frauen wieder gezwungen werden zu hause
zu bleiben
dann werde ich mein heimatland verlassen
müssen im zentrum von kabul hat einer
vor kurzem eine boutique eröffnet sie
nimmt uns mit dorthin
hier ist sie die chefin die angestellten
warten schon auf sie hat ihre eigene
modemarke unter ihrem namen kreiert sie
hat die chancen die sich für frauen in
den letzten 20 jahren geboten haben
genutzt
für sie war das westliche engagement in
ihrem land eine erfolgsgeschichte
ein erfolg um den sie nun fürchtet ich
glaube es ist kein guter zeitpunkt dass
amerika jetzt afghanistan verlassen will
die situation in der wir uns gerade
befinden ist völlig ungewiss
die amerikaner sollten zumindest so
lange bleiben bis sich alles geklärt hat
fast nichts mehr ist in kabul
selbstverständlich und schon gar nicht
eine yogastunde
maria montez will inneren frieden
vermitteln
in einem land das sich seit 50 jahren im
krieg befindet immer wieder wird das
yoga studio von religiösen fanatikern
bedroht die meinen yoga sei unislamisch
[Musik]
was ich praktiziere also yoga hat keine
verbindung zu den traditionen der
gesellschaft mir geht es mehr darum zu
sehen was die menschen brauchen
ich habe in yoga gezeigt und diese
menschen brauchen yoga wirklich nimm
deine linke hand auf dein linkes bein
und die rechte hand hoch und jetzt
schaut auf deine rechte hand 123 es geht
fach ria und den meisten ihrer
schülerinnen nicht um glauben es geht um
eine tiefe sehnsucht frieden
der weg zum frieden für afghanistan
führt über den inneren frieden das
wertfach herthas in ihren yogastunden
familienleben ist ihr wichtig jeden
mittag kocht sie für ihre fünf kinder
die älteste tochter vor hilft dabei sie
sind eine liberale familie marias man
unterstützt das yoga studio und auch
ihre 73 jährige mutter ist dabei die
yoga lehrerin ist inzwischen über die
grenzen afghanistans hinaus bekannt auch
wir haben uns im vergangenen jahr
bereits schon einmal mit ihr verabredet
doch dann erhielt sie plötzlich
morddrohungen von religiösen fanatikern
fast zwei monate musste das studio im
sommer geschlossen bleiben
nur zu hause und im yoga studio dürfen
wir ferrari mit der kamera begleiten
auf der straße hat sie angst sehr
prominente religiöse leute haben
begonnen unsere arbeit zu kommentieren
auch unsere bilder ein bekannter muller
erklärte uns den dschihad den heiligen
krieg
[Musik]
ein altes foto an der wand sagt fach
hier als erste yogaübungen als kind sie
war 19 jahre alt der floh sie mit ihren
eltern vor den taliban nach pakistan
2002 kehrte sie in ihre heimat zurück
yoga ist inzwischen auch familien ritual
selbst mit ihrer mutter praktizierte ja
jeden tag 15 minuten zu hause
[Musik]
mehr als 100 schülerinnen hat das studio
inzwischen frauen die jetzt alle um ihre
zukunft fürchten
die taliban dürften probleme mit den
errungenschaften haben mit dem was die
frauen erreicht haben es gibt einiges
was neuen unsere kultur gebracht wurde
für yoga die menschen achten inzwischen
gerechtes und frauen aber wir können das
was wir in 20 jahren erreicht haben
verlieren
ich habe hoffnung ich möchte dass die
taliban verstehen dass die afghanen
leben wollen wie andere menschen in der
welt wie sehr sich afghanistan verändert
hat zeigt sich ganz besonders in dieser
yoga stunde die frauen die sich auf
ihren matten strecken sind studentinnen
büroangestellte hausfrauen und sie sind
alle ziemlich mutig und selbstsicher der
kontrast zu den zeiten in denen die
taliban das land beherrschten und frauen
sich nur in burkas gehüllt mit gesenktem
kopf auf die straße trauen durften
könnte nicht größer sein
die afghanischen frauen wollen selbst
entscheiden welche arbeit sie nach
stehen
sie wollen selbst entscheiden was sie
lernen wegen sie reisen und wenn sie
heiraten afghanische frauen wollen
selbst ihre zukunft bestimmen die
afghanischen frauen mit denen es die
taliban heute zu tun haben sind nicht
mehr die gleichen und vor 20 jahren der
einzige weg uns zu stoppen ist uns zu
töten
es sind die kommenden monate die
entscheiden werden ob das land in alte
verhältnisse zurückfällt ob am
hindukusch ein neuer gottesstaat
entsteht
doch die entscheidungen werden nicht in
kabul und mindshare getroffen sondern
weit entfernt in washington und in doha
wo die regierungen teile der
zivilgesellschaft seit september mit den
taliban über frieden verhandeln
[Musik]
nur vier frauen sitzen mit am
verhandlungstisch wenn es darum geht zu
entscheiden welches land wird
afghanistan in zukunft sein
[Musik]